for millions of ukrainians there is no
evacuation plan if russia does invade
and they have been on edge for weeks and
now reuters is reporting a new claim by
russia charlie dagida is in kiev charlie
good morning
good morning russian military officials
say their guards killed five ukrainian
troops and destroyed two vehicles they
say a reconnaissance team trying to
cross into the border with russia the
ukrainians say that is fake news if true
it would be the first direct
confrontation between both sides only
adding to rising tensions here
in the most elaborate and choreographed
show of force yet
russia held military drills by land
sea
and air knowing full well it wasn't just
president vladimir putin watching
far more worrying is that announcement
that tens of thousands of russian troops
in belarus will remain indefinitely
despite previous pledges to pull them
out after joint drills poised to strike
along the border with ukraine
and it comes amid a dramatic escalation
and shelling from russian-backed
separatists on the front lines in
eastern ukraine
upping the propaganda war separatist
leaders warned of an impending assault
from ukrainian forces reporting that
tens of thousands of civilians have been
evacuated to russia for their own safety
raising fears that putin might use the
pretext of protecting ethnic russians to
justify an invasion
despite the ominous developments of the
past few days it's still business as
usual here in the capitol and although
there is a sense of calm here there's
also a growing sense of concern of
course i'm worried about my safety and
my family and my children of course
would you leave kiev
today no
i'm afraid
this is our motherland
our people
our children
in kiev hundreds of women took part in
survival and self-defense courses
ukrainians know their forces are no
match to the military might of russia
yet nobody here wants to believe a
full-scale invasion is either imminent
or inevitable
the sharp escalation in fighting in the
east is a real concern here we went to
the front lines over the weekend not far
from a sustained artillery attack and
commanders there said it's like nothing
they've seen in years
charlie dagetta and ukraine thank you